hier bist du was machst du das gleiche
wie du
jetzt bloß nicht kratzen jetzt wichtig
einfach aushalten können neugierige
können
international sind zum flucht verholfen
jetzt geht es dem kind geht es gut
sie waren durch gestellt machen sollen
nichts rechtfertigt im handel ist enorm
geld zu schauen
niemand hat das gestand lehmann hat es
geschafft
nicht nur auf sie müssen die transaktion
starten
nein ich hatte sie nicht autorisiert
natürlich ist das meine unterschrift
ich habe doch es ist meine schrift er
hat eine sofort überweisung getätigt
hat er vor sie wissen wo ist sie steckt
mit ihm und einer decke aber sie
schweigt zwar schon die ganze zeit ist
ihnen klar dass über mitwisserschaft für
jahre ins gefängnis gehen keine sorge
dass wir die politik besser erklären
können auf die werden wir noch eine
weile warten müssen
rufst du jetzt endlich die polizei hören
sie meine freundin hat weder ihre jacken
noch ihre tasche mit
ich bin sicher sie in der gewalt dieses
irren er geht es dir hast du dich
verletzt alles okay nichts weiter ich
hatte angst um dich um und wo genau so
lukas zuletzt gesehen in der tiefgarage
ist spurlos verschwunden und sie gehört
in der tiefgarage das büro lager
ich war mit ihm dort ich hatte meinen
skizzenblock vergessen das büro lager
liegt direkt in einem gang neben der
tiefgarage runter fahren sie die
tiefgarage
ich brauche deine hilfe
mist gespielt ist schon weg gewesen und
wahrscheinlich auch